as independent filmmaker I'm always
trying to find in a way to survive this
business and as we speak
the way people fund their films and they
do landscape is shifting all the time
now so have to reinvent ourselves and
the creative different ways to fundraise
I have done in the past several
Kickstarter and IndieGoGo those
platforms have been saturated to so many
people trying to no fun no deaf films
and then I realized that I should create
although no mechanism to fund my films I
use the way to sell my old enum items
that from my previous film after post
those items online and realized that it
went out pretty quick and then I felt
like that I could sell not all my actors
but everything I had in my closet Flavio
came up with an idea that that I thought
it could work and wanted to try it out
with him which is called eBay my film
calm and it's a similar version of
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo instead of
asking for money we asked people for
their goods that we could utilize to
sell to make money that's all French to
donate whatever they had in their
closets and we start with that then we
suffering add some different social
media pages and other people strange
people now sub donating their items as
well a month later had more than
thousand items posted on eBay and so the
initial goal was to raise $10,000 which
we reach pretty quick and because it
exceeded so fast the amount of funds
will recede so fast we decided to raise
the bar we exceeded 10 then we exceeded
20 and father said let's go to 50 and I
said let's go to 100 it only meant that
we had to work harder and sell more
items because it's not a passive income
actually you physically are still
involved which takes away from your
production it was a challenge because we
don't know how it would work and then we
Ginette experience like a posting and
shipping and we have a chill on
everything as we were doing the campaign
I advise anyone to start with a few
items now before they go big because it
is technically a production in itself so
which means
you have to put your production of the
film on hold in order to do this if you
want to raise the funds if any filmmaker
is interested in raising funds using
eBay they can always go to our website
eBay my film calm reach out to us which
we're happy to share our knowledge so
that they can reach their goal
first find yourself a fiscal sponsor you
need that that's a mandatory thing and
you can go to any fiscal sponsor we
worked with New York Foundation for the
Arts
they're there one of them they're great
there we love them but there are tons of
them out there you don't have to work
with that one specifically establish
that connection tell them that you want
to do this eBay campaign and if they're
willing to be a part of it because
they'll have to be willing to be a part
of it then you can reach out to you in
my firm calm and we're happy to set you
up raising money on eBay
I think is the feature for a few makers
storytellers or anyone interested to
sell to set a new campaign doesn't
necessarily have to be for a film could
it be for when could it be to go to
college could be anything
you